la réalité c'est que on mesure mal
aujourd'hui ces phénomènes là on les
mesure de façon parcellaire j'ai
quelques chiffres indiqués qui sont déjà
parlants 35000 agressions de
professionnel de santé remonté en 2021
35000 12000 actes d'inciibilité remonté
par les caisses d'allocation familial en
2022 pour vous donner quelques exemples
mais nous avons aujourd'hui une
difficulté j reviendrai à bien mesurer
et on peut être d'ors et déjà certain
qu'il y a une forme de allo au retour de
ces chiffres là sur les remontées qui
sont effectives et effectué ce qui est
certain quand on réunit les réseaux les
administrations tout le monde fait le
même constat il y a à la fois un enjeu
sur le nombre d'agressions mais il y a
aussi un enjeu sur l'intensité des
agressions que vivent les agents
d'ailleurs j'ai décidé de bannir le mot
incivilité de mon vocabulaire quand je
parlais de ces sujetsl je me suis rendu
compte à quel point il était parfois
contreproductif ce n'est pas des
incivilités que vivent les agents
publics ce sont des menaces et des
agressions euh la réalité c'est qu'il y
a quelques années on pouvait se dire que
on commençait par un dialogue un peu
hrité puis ça se terminait par des
menaces aujourd'hui tous les réseaux
nous remontte le fait que on démarre
plutôt par des menaces et parfois on va
au pire à des agressions à des cûts ou
parfois au drames que j'ai évoqué en en
introduisant et au fond ça montre qu'il
y a des causes exogènes et que les
services publics voient un certain
nombre de dérives de notre société
derrière les cas dramatiques que j'ai
mentionné sont parfois des sujets de
santé mental euh la professeur à
Saint-Jean de luuse c'était pas un cas
de radicalisation c'était un enjeu de
santé mentale parfois c'est le fait du
terrorisme de l'islamisme qui a touché
nos agents publics toutes les dérives de
notre société qui déferle et puis il
faut aussi avoir la lucidité de
constater qu'il y a parfois des causes
endogènes je le dis parce que c'est ce
que nous remontent nos administration
parfois des agents placés dans des
situations de devoir appliquer des
démarches administratif trop complexe
pas assez lisible d'être mis dans des
mauvaises conditions ben tout ça crée
aussi euh un sentiment d'irritation qui
peut ensuite arriver à l'agressivité
c'est le téléphone qui est pas décroché
c'est des temps d'attente très longs et
quand on on on discute notamment dans le
secteur hospitalier les agents publics
nous le disent parfois des agents des
des des patients qui ont attendu pendant
9h euh aux urgences bah oui ils sont
dans des situations où l'agressivité
vient plus vite et donc ça montre à quel
point il faut prendre ce sujet avec
humilité mais aussi travailler sur
toutes les causes euh y compris les
causes racines de notre propre
complexité administrative si on veut
essayer de de de pouvoir progresser